welcome faculty panelists and friends
thank you for attending this year's
Kenneth Cole community engagement forum
today's theme has been the power of
community engagement impact innovation
and the individual during this our final
panel we will learn about forming a
global community more specifically we
will discuss power of social media to
connect individuals and foster social
change this past summer I along with
four other Kenneth Cole community
engagement fellows had the opportunity
to witness firsthand the potential
social media has to keep community
members engaged and apprised of the
happenings in their surroundings we
worked for ten weeks at Community League
of the heights cloth a nonprofit in
southern Washington Heights cloth opened
its doors in 1952 and ever since has
been dedicated to improving the life of
its area's residents the organization
provides after-school programming and
affordable housing operates a food
pantry health clinic and Technology
Center along with providing an array of
other social services in 2006 cloth
reached an organizational milestone when
it opened community health academy of
the heights in a partnership with new
visions for public schools the new
york-presbyterian hospital and the
Columbia Medical Center the new middle
and high school focused on preparing its
students for college while
simultaneously giving them experience in
the health care field cloth solicited
the help of the kenneth cole fellows in
order to prepare for new major
development in September 2012 cloth is
opening the Lucille Bulger Center for
Community Life which will has community
health academy of the heights during
school days but will also provide
programming and services for the entire
community during weeknights and weekends
the fellows were tasked with executing a
community assessment to gauge the wants
and needs of the area in order to ensure
that the community centers programming
would accurately reflect cloths
constituents desires a diverse
population of children adults seniors
out-of-school youth and families
although this was our initial goal we
soon realized that we had much more to
accomplish some of the center's closest
neighbors were not even aware its
facilities would be available to them a
key component of our mission became the
publication of cloths involvement in the
community and its goals it became each
fellows individual duty to communicate
with class constituents it became each
individual's duty to reach out and find
someone to teach about the center and
consequently from whom to learn about
life in Washington Heights that we
gathered much into information about the
wants and needs of community members
with respect to the new center above all
else our summer experience taught us
that communication is an integral part
of any community organizations success
and communication barriers are a
difficult impediment to overcome over
the past decade our world has witnessed
a revolution in the way it communicates
the Internet has made it possible for
messages to travel faster than ever
before facebook facebook and twitter
have given people forums to connect and
create networks larger than were
previously imaginable but what good are
these changed forms of communication
faster connections and larger networks
if they fail to change the world what
good is a friend or a contact it's a
connection between the individuals has
no substance now that our technology has
become so advanced and commonplace it is
time to put it to work as an agent of
social change as I learned this summer
no longer is word of mouth the only tool
available to small organizations with
limited resources and as we have all
learned over the past year with
movements such as that in Egypt and on
our very own Wall Street individuals
have more power than ever before to
create true change by finding those who
are like-minded and equally motivated in
today's final panel we will have a
chance to discuss exactly how social
media has allowed for individuals to get
involved and have an impact and perhaps
what barriers social media has yet to
overcome in the realm of social activism
few have had as much experience
harnessing the power of social media to
create social change as our
distinguished panelists mark bolinsky
Becca economic Willis and professor Ted
Perlmutter this afternoon each panelist
will speak about their experiences and
introduce their work followed by a panel
discussion and open Q&A before we begin
let me introduce today's moderator Sri
Srinivasan named one of add ages 25
media people to follow on Twitter and
one of the 35 most influential people in
social media by pointer org professor
Srinivasan is Dean of Students Steen of
student affairs at Columbia University's
Graduate School of Journalism where he
teaches in the digital media program
including media entrepreneurship now
please help me in welcoming professor
Srinivasan along with our panelists as
they discuss the benefits and challenges
inherent in connecting a global
community hi everyone i think i'm
supposed to be sitting there but i'm
just more comfortable as a professor
standing but i will go back and sit down
thank you very much for having me here
and you have you're in for a treat
because you have some fabulous speakers
who are going to guide you through the
world of social media and social change
I just wanted to make a couple quick
observations the first is that we've
been teaching social media at the
journalism school for about four years
now and the first time I had a class for
credit I said to my students if your
parents knew you were paying Columbia
tuition to take a class in facebook and
twitter that call my boss Nicholas lemon
and get me fired so we've got to kind of
think about how you can teach social
media in a kind of strategic manner for
journalists and other folks and now fast
forward to this past week where I
started another section of my course
it's a five week course and we had very
you know young graduate students 22 23
years old learning about how to use
Twitter something they've already been
using or Facebook something they're
already using how to use it kind of in
smarter ways and one
my messages to folks who are here is
that you'll be seeing a lot of the big
picture stuff and some of the tactical
things people are doing and we'll try to
have that conversation but the most
important thing is to kind of keep
practicing and and trying all all the
stuff that's out there and I recommend
being an early tester and late adopter
like I am so that you don't have to be
the first in any of these technologies
but whenever you're ready make sure it
makes sense for you to be there the next
thing I just wanted to say was that
there's an article about social media
and social change written in October of
2010 by the great Malcolm Gladwell who
many of you know and are great admirers
of like I am and Malcolm basically said
in this article that social media cannot
make social change and about three
months later we saw in January the start
of the Arab Spring Tunisia Egypt etc and
there were two reactions to what what
happened there so some people called it
a social media revolution and I don't
think that that's correct it's not a
social media revolution that happened it
was a real revolution with people
willing to stand up and fight and be
beaten and give give up real blood and
their safety and everything else that's
what it took but social media helped
accelerate it social media helped get
everything out there in faster and more
important and strategic ways and that's
why you need kind of social media as
well as the the the old ways of
communicating and people who are willing
to do things kind of physically to make
things happen but there are other people
who also felt that Malcolm Gladwell was
spectacularly wrong and the reason he
was wrong and I agree with them that
when his article i think was incorrect
and you'll hear from the some of the
work of my colleagues up here about what
social media can do but the reason he
was wrong by the way was because he was
not a user of social media himself he is
not on facebook not on Twitter certainly
not when the article came out and you
will need to
a chef to be a food critic you don't
need to be a filmmaker to be a film
critic Roger Ebert certainly was not a
filmmaker but it is very trusted and
beloved film critic by the way a
terrific Twitter presence if you haven't
followed him is Ebert Chicago you must
follow him if you were interested in the
movie business anyway so you don't have
to do those things to be those in those
other fields but you certainly have had
to have watched a movie in a theater or
eaten in a restaurant to be a food or
film critic and I think the people who
criticize social media without being on
it are as unconnected and as unaware of
what it can truly do until you're on
there at the same time people who /
promise what social media can do also
have to be very careful about this so i
just wanted to show you this slide is
from a famous image of the egyptian
internet connections and as you know the
the story in egypt started in around
january twenty fifth and in fact the
famous hashtag was hash jam 25 and by
the 27th you can see you know kind of
spike in internet traffic and then it
shut down and that was the government of
Egypt kind of very consciously saying
we've got to worry about what social
media and digital media can do and I
when I when this was circulated somebody
had a great tweet about this they said
the government of Egypt shut down the
internet so that Malcolm Gladwell would
not be wrong that's how much Hosni
Mubarak was a fan of Malcolm Gladwell
because everybody is a fan of Malcolm
Gladwell and and so I wrote an article
about the things i learned from egypt
and that's that big URL you see there
bit ly / DNA Egypt where I kind of
discuss what I learned about about
social media but if anyone ever tells
you that social media cannot cause
social change think about this slide and
think about this image and you I think
it helps you think about the the the
start of that conversation well now on
to
panelists and i'm going to introduce
each one and then they're going to come
up here and or i guess you're going to
stay there but becca you're going to
stay there and you're going to come up
ok so our speakers are Becca economic
police who is a senior strategist at
fission strategy she's at 15 years
experience as a grassroots field and
online organizer working with local
national and international NGOs and
activists mobilizations her twitter
handle is becca m OPB e kam opie and i
hope you will follow her on twitter
please give her a hand and welcome her
our next speaker is going to be mark
bilinski mark is president and founder
of digital democracy which brings
experiences and he brings experiences
working in technology media and civil
society for more than five years with
projects extending from Europe the
Middle East the Caucasus to South and
Southeast Asia southern Africa and the
United States his twitter handle is m
bolinsky be e li n sk why I hope you'll
follow him please welcome mark and Ted
Perlmutter is a lecturer in the
negotiation and resolute conflict
resolution program at Columbia where he
teaches conflict social networks and
communications technology and is an
adjunct associate professor in the MS
program in global affairs at NYU where
he teaches global civil society his
twitter handle is ted pearl te d PE r l
we're using the hashtag co forum co le
fo r um which we kind of decided to use
on the fly so if you're tweeting we hope
you'll use that but let's start with
backup please come on up well we didn't
put in a plug thanks so I really a few
hats and this presentation is coming
from the perspective of one of those
hats
um alright you good
uh maybe tech can come look at it and
I'll talk in the meantime so in addition
to my background as a traditional field
organizer and then an online organizer
now doing strategy for great thank you
nonprofits and foundations I have been
for the last month or so kind of working
full time over at Occupy Wall Street in
a variety of capacities including
helping to anchor the PR thank you I
mean to everyone and to anchor the PR
operation and some of the digital media
work but then I also when help run an
Arts Collective and nonprofit in
Brooklyn called not an alternative so
that's where I can you know I've got the
world of the practical and the doing and
then the world of theory and curation
and critique um and so I thought it
might be a nice way to start this panel
off because it's kind of easy to zoom
into Arab Spring or occupy wall street
and evangelize the role of social media
I mean I'm already in crime already
there right but in general I think we
should complexification around social
media for social change because often it
amounts to moving the furniture around
the room a whole lot I'm so that's the
perspective that that I'm going to speak
from so first how do we define the
contemporary landscape so we have you
know one of the greatest gaps between
rich and poor right now concentration of
wealth environmental collapse and
exploitation of labor and resources so
that is how some might to find the
contemporary landscape and in response
to it you know we're defining the
problem as power from above a broken
democracy or institutions are
destructive or heavier
bureaucratic or unresponsive to the
environment and some of the solutions
then our sustainability and green
products and localism looking through
the environmental lens but in in general
then like crowdsourcing and engagement
and participation and make your own
solution stuff right so here's the DIY
City how do you want to reinvent your
city and in inviting people to
participate in these closed structures
right and open them up open-source the
city NYC big apps if you all have heard
of that it's a great competition
software challenge inviting people to
participate in New York City's drive to
become more transparent accessible and
accountable so this crowd sourcing and
working outside of bureaucracy and
outside of the institution so how many
of you remember the time magazine cover
when was that 2006 or something Person
of the Year is you it was especially was
a closely guarded secret I remember the
reading a story about the factory
producing the mylar for the covers of
Time Warner and the confidentiality
agreements they had a sign and so on and
so you could look into the little
computer screen and see yourself and
this was at the exact same time that the
World Economic Forum was meeting in
Davos Switzerland some of the global
leaders as well as wealthiest
corporations in the world and putting as
one of the top two agenda items the
shift of the balance of power from the
global elite to the individual as
evidence through the rise of the
blogosphere in social media so so this
is the landscape and I would argue some
of the rhetoric and that there's a deep
belief that when horizontal structures
of participation replace top-down
mechanisms of control
hierarchy and authoritarianism this will
eliminate apathy and disenfranchisement
and so in response to the problem of
power from above we erase hierarchies we
distribute the tools of media production
we give everyone everywhere voice and it
means to participate power from below
those are all good things right the
problem is it's an antiquated definition
of power so we need to map our activity
user solutions etc to a more
contemporary understanding of how to
power of functions I would argue it's no
longer operating exclusively from above
from some centralized command and
control it's it's you know if that is
our understanding of it then it's no
wonder that we're latching on to notions
of openness transparency and
participation as radical ends in and of
themselves right but we can't fetishize
process over product participatory
frameworks are not in the of themselves
politically significant nor is power
limited to distant and impersonal
structures we believe that power is
diffused and distributed and it operates
through us and on us so you know some
examples you are integrated into systems
or participation whether you want to be
here now here's a Facebook photo and
Adrian Bell is tagged and she's never
created a facebook profile there are
many examples of this strategies of
refusal thus are resistant no are futile
you know in another example like a
crisis of representation we come up with
solutions but then they're integrated
directly and become a fuel for a system
that is fundamentally unsustainable so
here's a lot of the vocabulary
you know the alternative culture
subculture this is an advertisement for
williamsburg condos right so that you
know DIY proclivities like we've got our
rooftop gardens and route but there's
this great quote from from a woman who
spoke at our space recently goldman
sachs doesn't care if you raise chickens
to put it into a little perspective so
this system is constantly producing
alternatives and we offer solutions that
are so quickly integrated without
pressuring anything to change so without
challenging or transforming a given
system the more that we decentralize
there are still institutions with large
amounts of control and we come up with
solutions to problems that we see as
being alternatives they are sucked into
the brand identities of these larger
institutions that have adopted this form
so then there's no pressure on these
institutions to really meaningfully
substantively change so there's these
inherent contradictions that are enabled
in a space is created for these
contradictions to grow because again
there's not like a direct pressure to
change for example we're all about green
solutions but then the coal industry
comes up with clean coal or VP becomes
beyond petroleum all right so these
companies are becoming grain without
changing and our desires for grimness
and our designs are integrated into
their brand and here's the obama change
we can believe in and I a lot written up
about the the branding of the Obama
campaign and here's Pepsi and
Pepsi believes no bot you know this they
would never say that this is any kind of
direct reference but we know how
advertising works and that's the an
effort to determine our understanding of
things so these examples of co-optation
are prevalent but it's important to look
at house absorption function
specifically in the information age the
social media age our relationships are
like sour dislikes are monetized
demographic data is for their fuelling
advertising marketing and consumption so
we have four square in face big Facebook
and place-based social networking games
come marketing schemes now
personalization and micro targeting
google search engine results you are the
individual you are your world the Time
magazine cover so we are ostensibly
distributing power but as we're doing
that we are also in burdening capitalism
we've solved the problem that capitalism
faced in the 90s the ironic
individualized generation media savvy
deconstructionist to read their Chomsky
rejecting the voice of authority how
many of you are familiar with a clue
train manifesto so this is a seminal
piece of work that really like blade
right yep yes so I'm going to read a
little excerpt of it is branding
marketing excerpts gurus involved in
industry and they wrote a little over 10
years ago now the chlorine manifesto
which begins markets or conversations
these markets are conversations their
members communicate in language that is
natural open honest direct funny and
often shocking weather explaining or
complaining joking or serious the human
voice is unmistakeably genuine it can't
be faked most corporations on the other
hand
you know how to talk in the soothing
humorless monotone of the mission
statement marketing brochure and your
call is important to us busy signal same
old tone same old lies no wonder
networked markets have no respect for
companies unable or unwilling to speak
as they do but learning to speak in a
human voice is not some trick normal
corporations convince us they are human
with lip service about listening to
consumers they will only sound human
when they empower real human beings to
speak on their behalf and this is
something that social media in many ways
has gifted to these marketing gurus
right more than dismantling or
distributing power we've invisible eyes
dit and extended it so just one example
you know the coutry manifesto maybe not
directly but it like put put its finger
on a zeitgeist in a changing information
Turin and it you know very much around
that time was the rise of reality
television and then ultimately reality
advertising moving into social media
marketing and this is a screenshot from
one video and if you guys remember this
but Kleenex kimberly-clark corporation
had this campaign that performed very
well online it they were one of the
first companies actually to hire a CML
ever so those achieve marketing officers
specifically was dealing with social
media and so this at the time that it
came out in two thousand six or so was
very innovative advertising and they had
I actor hired to perform as I could be a
psychotherapist
but a little blue ikea couch in public
space in different cities around the
country and invited people to let it out
give us your kleenex movement your tear
jerking story you know what tugs at the
heartstrings because there's no better
way to than to integrate rather than you
know actors telling you how great
kleenexes integrating these really real
moments authenticity right into the ad
campaign and then at some point you know
they reach for the Kleenex um so at the
time i was running green pieces online
organizing program and one thing that we
did was send our people in with cameras
and hidden microphones and they went and
gave their interviews as well they're
Kleenex moment stories but at some point
it would go you know they would ask what
you know what makes you cry what makes
you what whatever and and it was you
know there would be the transition in
the interview and the other thing is you
know these tissues are made out of one
hundred percent virgin fiber source from
the boreal forest and one in Canada like
ancient forest grown over hundreds of
years and no sustainable logging
practices and so and then we created our
own commercial out of this it looked
just like the clinic's commercial had
the music had the actor and so on but
had these moments of rupture and put
that online and got actually
substantially more views than the
original Kleenex commercial and so that
so to me it again going back to that the
product versus process you know like
evangelizing the platform in the form
versus the ends to which it's directed
everyone today sings the praises of
participation meaning academics hail
audiences who remix commercial culture
web 20 executives and marketing experts
applaud openness and connectivity
conservative economists who discover the
benefits of collaboration interactivity
engagement are the highest ideals of the
new order ideal is taken by many to be
synonymous with democracy participation
is perceived as politics in vice versa
and this fantasy is a powerful one
postulating as it does the invitation
and inclusion of everyone everywhere and
the internet we are told makes these
dreams a reality erasing borders and
distinctions smoothing out differences
in hierarchies we are all equal now
because everyone's voice can be heard so
political theorist Jody ten calls this
communicative capitalism an ideological
formation that fetishizes speech opinion
and participation it embeds us in a
mindset where in the number of friends
one has on Facebook the number of page
hits one gets on one's blog in the
number of videos on one's YouTube
channel are key markers of success in
details such as duration depth of
commitment corporate and financial
influence access to structures of
decision making and the narrowing of
political struggle to the standards of
do-it-yourself entertainment culture
become the boring preoccupations of baby
boomers stuck in the past and to welcome
to the age of interactivity with
participation into everything and
nothing every action is subsumed by this
new framework including our very
sociability our likes our desires are
hurt feds comments and curiosities are
mindless searches and indiscriminate
clicks which our mind aniline analyzed
and monetized by the new power brokers
so here all the time besieged to
participate to choose to vote to share
to join in to like but we're already
integrated into these structures whether
we like it or not and our concern is
that a veneer of engagement only
obscures deep flaws in the participation
paradigm so covered some of that but if
participatory frameworks all right I'll
have any meaningful political
consequence or activist import social
change as the theme and
then must intervene on some objects to
operate in service of an end and
conflict often isn't necessary results
of such a collaboration in a key driving
force within it current conversations
around participation idealize harmony
and inclusion in unison but we asked
whether synthesizing perspectives and
Valerie's and consensus can subdue
dissenting viewpoints and it through the
tyranny of compromise in the rule the
lowest common denominator and some of
this view we fear a disavowal power
rather than honest discussion of it and
so that's just attempting to set up a
bit of the framework where you know it's
exciting to point to Arab Spring into
wall street and other examples of social
media for social change very often
outside of the contexts of those
subjects there is just a kind of
pervasive overall evangelism that to me
it's just important that we understand
what exactly is going on and what what
is exciting and what is potentially an
illusion right so that's it
hi everyone thank you so much for having
me and Becca that was a sort of a
fantastic description of something that
i would love to build upon i think a lot
of what i'm going to talk about is how
that applies to the actual concept of
democracy itself we see this rise of
democratic countries all around the
world such as Russia and and otherwise
and what does that really mean how much
are people participating actively
engaging in the processes of their
democracy throughout the past several
decades the way that democracy has
really been defined for most
international work has been through
elections and and that is a
unfortunately lackluster definition of
democracy that people around the world
have really come to believe and
appreciate in so many ways and yet
there's this opportunity for a rise in
global solidarity and a rise in a new
definition where people can start to
define participation for themselves when
it's connected to action specifically so
I run an organization that i co-founded
called digital democracy and our focus
is utilizing digital tools to empower
marginalized communities around the
world for their human rights and the the
focus there is really that marginalized
communities need to go from the outside
to the from the margins of the
conversation to the center of
conversations in order for democracies
to really be fully realized within their
own countries without the proper rights
of minorities it's very difficult to
show the actual existence of democracy
in one's own country and so we work on a
variety of places we've now worked in 24
countries around the world specifically
focused right now on a systematic
approach to
stopping rape in Haiti having women's
groups local women's groups aggregate
data on instances of violence so they
can then hold their government to
account so it's very much utilizing
digital tools to have a legal argument
where they can push their their
government and authorities into driving
actual action and if they don't then
prosecuting them at the international
level in order to ensure that forcing of
action and so we work from programming
to actual case studies and and and to us
it's really helping to define democracy
in the 21st century built on the
standards of the universal declaration
of human rights Human Rights often in
the past has not looked specifically at
article 19 the the the right that
everyone has to access information and
the implications that that has in the
21st century as we start to utilize more
and more digital tools and the
questioning of who actually controls
those tools controls that ability to
speak so I want to do a little quick
survey of in the audience default
browsers I'm very curious who who uses
google chrome as their default browser
all right so we have a pretty good chunk
of the room all right what about
Internet Explorer all right there's
there's one I want I want out you on
that Safari all right some mac users
opera any Norwegians and what about
Firefox all right so i think google
chrome one now i love this guy he is a
beautiful beautiful thing what we like
to say is that there's actually a
democracy in the code
of firefox it isn't a free and
open-source project and so the code that
it's written on can be seen and built
upon by any and all users and the code
itself is therefore participatory its
accountable it's transparent if it's not
in your language you can translate it
into your language because everybody's
eyes can see it if there's a specific
security exploit it's in the entire
community's interest to fix that exploit
there's a large plug in infrastructure
it's it's a constantly growing thing and
even itself is a symbol of a democracy
that was never before possible until the
21st century we're 30,000 people from
around the world have contributed to the
betterment of this code and not for any
monetary benefit but rather for the
benefit of the community itself and as
we consider these digital tools that
were engaged with what is the
responsibility that we have when
engaging with them to understand the
political implications facebook is now
the third largest country in the world
if you were to take just the number of
people who are on it about 600 million
users its gdp would also be much much
larger than most of the countries in the
world does anybody want to guess what
the second largest democracy is
Wikipedia and yet they have banners from
there the head of the organization
pleading for people to give it money so
in the 21st century we really look at
the confluence of digital literacy
digital organizing and digital
governments as the new systems that are
necessary for people to understand if
they're to engage proactively in a 21st
century democracy so what we mean by
digital literacy this is a funny a prism
that I think is a very powerful tool
Google before you tweet is the new think
before you speak
right in order for people to understand
and engage in journalism there's a level
of media literacy that's necessary to
become engaged citizens in a democracy
if you don't understand the media you
can be exploited by it and similarly we
are engaging more and more with digital
technologies and people don't
necessarily understand the the
truthiness of the information that
they're encountering or even how to
engage proactively when documenting
instances of abuse of attacks of what's
happening in their community in a way
where it can be trusted verified
information to build the conversation
and the greater media etc so I'm really
going to focus on the the case of Egypt
as a specific study where I am going to
bring in a bit of a more cynical
approach my parents came here as
refugees from the Soviet Union so I have
a cynical Russian view of many things
but so looking at what happened in
Tahrir Square was a very exciting moment
and when we can discuss the the power
that technology had or do not have in
causing this revolution but I think
what's very interesting is the specifics
of how the technology was used and even
the perspective that this is a poster by
a girl in Tahrir Square understanding
the world through the digital lens and I
think that we're increasingly coming to
that reality where if we don't
understand how to manipulate and hack
that digital lens than we are forced to
be structured solely by that structure
but for digital literacy it's knowing
what these technologies can do and
proactively engaging digital organizing
with Facebook was a very interesting
example of people coming together
setting a date for the revolution
generate 25th revolution be there
nothing like that had ever been tried
before at the same time in Egypt there's
one hundred and fifty percent cell phone
penetration it's not that everyone has a
cell phone but many people have several
cell phones however at the same time the
people who have access to Facebook are
an educated wealthier class of people
who who can participate in a
conversation that's largely built on an
english-language framework and so the
need to understand those very real
situations when discussing whether this
was a Facebook revolution or not because
that has pretty extreme implications for
instance who knows who this guy is so
Google executive or Google marketing
employee Wael Ghonim is often heralded
especially in the United States as one
of the leaders of the revolution he
himself says that he is not a leader
that it was wiki revolution and the
language of wiki revolution I think
speaks so loudly because of the
democratic principles of the wiki itself
but this is his Twitter icon and despite
being a Google employee he still tweets
and the question is whether he's Pharaoh
or facilitator right so he was one of
the administrators on the Facebook page
that said hey revolution join it this is
the Arabic language version of that same
page however he has he had an anonymous
profile he did not have his real name
and so when tens of thousands of people
started joining the we are all halide
syed facebook page this was a flag for
facebook briefly Khalid syed was a
blogger and computer programmer in in
egypt and he was brutally killed by the
police and that image circulated vary
widely in the Egyptian and Arab
blogosphere and so the we are all
holidays I Facebook page then became the
central point of the online revolution
but like i said the administrators were
not there publicly they were anonymous
and this goes against Facebook's policy
their real name policy and so when they
started to see tens of thousands of
people joining us we were all Holly and
Sayid and Facebook page they closed the
page can't have an anonymous page this
is wrong and so they decided that they
were going to put their real names on to
this page and so they change their
profiles publicly came out the website
went back up they were the next day
disappeared by Egyptian authorities and
so the ramifications of a decision that
was made in California has extreme
political consequence halfway around the
world and led to the disappearance of
these people now the Egyptian regime had
has been very sophisticated in
technology monitoring as well they've
been disappearing many people
intimidating many people calling them up
threatening their families because of
the insecure standards that a lot of
these technologies are built on who here
uses yahoo email sorry yahoo email so
it's understanding when you use yahoo
every message that you're sending is
sent as a postcard because it doesn't
have an encryption standard and so then
everybody can see what's written on that
message many human rights activists
around the world do not understand the
implications of this nor should they
necessarily understand that but the
privacy and security standards are not
built in as defaults and so even that
converse the the places that are these
conversational points these privately
owned spaces that are places for public
discussion have a lot of difficulties
and we don't necessarily have court
systems currently that understand how to
really drive a more positive
conversation or how to regulate or
encourage security and privacy standards
within the technology space and this is
an example of the power of cell phones
which are often under played when
talking about the Twitter and Facebook
revolutions that are occurring the army
sends out a message every single day to
every single person in the country so
basically the gist is revolutions over
thanks guys go home and they are able to
from a centralized point continue to
have this solid message unfortunately
whereas revolution is unfortunately
revolution is easy compared to democracy
and the excitement around the revolution
is to me partially a misunderstanding
about the role that digital tools can
play in a democracy and I think speaks
loudly to what Becca was saying it's
that you can participate in the
revolution you can go out you can
protest you can do it digitally but if
you don't have the definitions and the
tool sets to proactively engage in a
meaningful way but you participate in
the virtual sense of participation that
we all have been engaging with with
pokes and likes etc then you don't know
how to grab control of the reins of
power one of my friends that I was with
a couple of days ago in San Francisco as
soon as he landed in San Francisco got a
message from the authorities in Egypt
saying that he's going in front of
military tribunal he's a very active
blogger and because of his blogging he
is now going to most likely get at least
a decade in prison since the revolution
and because of his actions since the
revolution but there are unique
opportunities growing how to and
challenges around how to utilize these
digital tools in new ways to engage a
more proactive conversation now while
going him after he was released from
prison
put up Egypt to point o a Google
moderator discussion about what should
happen with the future of the country
and it's very exciting database to look
at it's not completely public but we
worked with Google to actually get the
raw data and the Arabic that's used is
basic street Arabic and so you can see
the language that is used is more
natural and open and more of the people
and the ideas really generated from them
the problem is that this is a laundry
list just like Google listings you're
very unlikely to go to page three item
five and click on it so if your idea is
on page three and it's item five then
how are you actually going to
participate in a meaningful way a troll
can get one issue and vote that up for
instance if you really want to legalize
marijuana in Egypt you know you might
have all of your people just click on
that one issue and get that to the top
which is what happened in the US when
Obama tried this we don't have
democratic user interfaces we don't have
democratizing tools all of these
perspectives are very still very young
so for those of you who don't have good
Arabic we took the ideas from this
database and have been experimenting
with a new new types of systems and are
constantly exploring what kinds of
options are there for more democratic
participation when faced with a
challenge of mass the need for mass
real-time collaboration and the lack of
opportunities here so some friends from
the Middle East and US were very upset
with the idea that the Western media was
saying this is what Arabs think
democracy is or that is what Arabs think
democracy is and said well why don't we
actually just ask them and give them a
way to participate themselves in that
conversation and so this system that we
built upon all our ideas takes a
database of ideas and just pits one
against another in a randomized set of
ways and so through
system we've really seen good ideas
starting to bubble up to the top which
has been very exciting and we have now
launched that with the Occupy Wall
Street protests asking the protesters
themselves and people and participants
from around the world what is it that
you want to see to fix this what are
what are the demands not to set the
demands but to drive a conversation and
the the power of citizens to be public
diplomats Tony baloney is the now Fame
infamous NYPD officer that maced some
girls in the face at the Occupy Wall
Street protests here in New York and the
power for somebody like that to then
have front-page news all around the
world this is a shot from earlier today
in Tahrir Square where Egyptians are
protesting in Tahrir Square because of
the brutal police brute because of the
police brutality that occurred in
Oakland California when the Occupy Wall
Street protests were broken up and the
signs are saying we stand in solidarity
with the occupy wall street protesters
just as the Occupy Wall Street
protesters are standing in solidarity
with the protesters fighting for
democracy in Egypt trying to define
democracy as participation in an
accountable transparent democracy so
just to end off I want to say that this
is a Egypt was was really just battle
one when the Mubarak regime fell and
it's very exciting but it's very
necessary to continue to follow that
conversation and understand how we in
our own democracy participate in helping
to drive positive change in in Egypt
when they can point the fingers to our
police brutality or to our Patriot Act
that makes it much more difficult to to
sustained Digital democracy or tangible
democracy in people's own countries so
thank you so much and I look forward to
to your questions and comments mr. mark
all right we've got hey did I just get
my little image squishes as ragging time
yeah that's it leave it there maximize
it later on
I think the son of the the interesting
and sort of fun thing about you know
about today is it gives people a chance
to sort of go against type in the sense
that the Beckett who spends most of her
days doing very practical organizing got
a chance to sort of give us or
theoretical version or vision of what
the limits on participation are who
spent most of my time sort of talking
and in broad terms about global civil
society and the role of communications
technology I'm going to sort of use this
you know hopefully a short period of
time to sort of talk about my own kind
of personal history of advocacy because
I think I'm the only one here who's
history of advocacy ants actually
happened before the internet and also I
want to make that argument partially to
sort of give some you know to give a
sense of what the power is there and
then to sort of end up in some extent to
some extent sort of talking about the
challenge of doing this in really
difficult places and speak to some
experiences that I had in Iraq in 2004
and 2006 trying to get Iraqis to use
communications technology so I think the
first point that has to be made is that
we've had global movements we've had you
know sort of global humanitarian global
social movements for a long time does
anybody here sort of know what were the
are the two most important movements of
the 1900s that could be called little
global movements no no historians in the
room so there were two things one of
which was anti-slavery and the other
which was women's suffrage now the
interesting part about both of these is
they're not usually seen as global
movements are usually seen as only
things which happened in the US but if
you actually go back and look at the
history you can sort of see you really
can understand what was happening at
that point but the question well how do
you actually do a global movement during
that period you had pamphlets you had
booklets but the real thing was you had
people who would go you know there's a
loan for the Women's International mins
Temperance Union who was actually
interested in women's suffrage who went
you know they still could 84 different
countries and I can assure you this took
a lot longer than took mark
to go to 24 countries in the sense that
people literally spent years trying to
figure how you build these networks up
so second point is sort of my sort of
experiences as I said of an anti-vietnam
activist and it really sort of started I
guess you know Mexican in 1972 which was
sort of after the peak of these
movements but at a time at which you
know i was at wesleyan at the time and
and we were still trying to know what
can you do at that point and i recall so
going down driving from sort of a
Middletown Connecticut down to Yale and
New Haven to hear sort of Jane Fonda
speak and also to hear the sort of
obscure guy named Fred Brafman with
something called the air war slideshow
now I'm Jane Fonda was somewhat of a
disappointment but she really was an
apologist from the Vietnamese at that
point I had to say it but that's really
what she was doing but Fred Hampton was
interesting because he sort of said well
this is really what it looks like when
you sort of you know Lane land mines
over North Vietnam at night and he had
this in this little slideshow I'm you
know sort of popped up 20 you know 20
different slides and you know and that
was actually the most impressive you
know idea of this so I then went back to
Wesleyan and you know we tried to figure
out how could we organize this campus
and then how can you know I personally
just let us show this kind of slide show
I'm organizing the campus what was
interesting there was very hard actually
fear what was going on any place else
because you know we knew it was
happening Wilson we might have known was
happening yell but was very unfair was
happening at Harvard at that point and
in fact it wasn't sort of until years
later that I actually figured out where
the demands came from because we and you
know it really was a much more isolated
sort of experience and similarly with
this kind of air war slideshow basically
and I was I sort of went around and
found groups of 20 people and showed
them the slideshow and tried to get them
to do something well I said of rapidly
exhausted the you know the number of you
like i said this show the slideshow too
and i really felt like I didn't have
very much voice and as I was sort of
thinking about this i was saying well
you know what was the problem there and
I sort of came back to the screen and
actually that I guess it's a lead into a
song by a group called Country Joe of
the fish
which was showing it was trying to make
an anti-war song at Woodstock and his
question why and you couldn't have been
his things like early in the morning
have been there for 48 hours they were
wet they were tired and he said how the
hell can I how the hell can you end the
war you can't sing any louder than this
and that was very much the impression
that I had a feeling of being an
activist at that particular time was you
know that our ability to sort of project
what we were doing just didn't really
exist and then the second point on ours
by sort of little venture into the
future is I woke up in 1997 and
discovered that a whole new class of
weapons had been banned there was
international commuted damn landmines
and I was having us think about other
things and it was precisely on the kind
of issues which we defined be able to
get people's interest 25 years ago and
Vietnam now how did this happen well
part of the reason it happened in sort
of a change in global political
alignments part of which was just the
sort of birth of you know belief in a
global civil society but elaborate was
really this new on this end of the
internet which made it possible zuv
construct Lobel relations between places
in the north where you have this sort of
the power to have influenced or what the
UN was doing and you know sort of in the
south where these issues were sort of
happened and it was also a case where
literally the internet created the issue
because before you had the movement
people really didn't know how many
people were dying of landmines so it
really was a case where leaner sort of a
combination of a new form of politics
and a new form of technology made
possible a certain set of you know
politics with which are no longer you
know which had previously not existed
and if you actually need to sort of look
at what Jodi Williams who got the Nobel
Prize in 1997 for doing this said she
said yeah no internet no movement this
was really not possible you really
couldn't sort of get and communicate
those kinds of images and I sort of want
to pop and they actually know you know
some somewhat like Becca's you know sort
of campaigns dealing with your kleenex
had come up with a very imaginative
strategies for thinking about this and I
actually want to show you one thing
which I suspect people have not seen see
if I can get the evil mouse to move on
ok Will Smith yeah I can never get max
to cooperate oh there we go
Oh
let you go
so and I sure showed this thing for two
reasons one of which is you know a
groups that are came up with this put it
on the internet but they originally put
it on it originally had in mind sort of
doing this as a TV commercial but
problem none of you ever seen it because
the American media decided this was too
violent to show and I've said you know
make this point 12 so there's a limits
to media but there was also much there
was a power to sort of do this and also
to sort of segue into my server brief
conversation about my time in Iraq where
I was trying to convince Iraqis to use
social media and this was a project
actually sponsored by the center for
international conflict resolution here
at Columbia University and we feel and
we found a very good group of peace
builders and who were very interested
asked her and went there is that are set
up and sort of show people how to use
the technology but I rapidly discovered
them rocky I was working said it's not
going to work I said well why is it
going to work on taking understand the
technology we have an improper interface
all the questions that Mark would have
solved had he been there but the problem
really wasn't the technological problems
the problem was that Iraqis didn't trust
in them so they said if we put these
documents up people are either going to
take credit for them or they're going to
deface them hmm I said no that can't be
the case so I found my racket in page
was too cynical um but then I I think I
sort of you know when the hotel rooms
that I showed this stuff that five or
six different groups every single group
said we won't do it unless you can
guarantee against these two sorts of
things and one and what to me this
really shows that you really have to be
very sensitive to the communities that
you're dealing with to figure what
they're you know what they're willing to
do so it's you know it's very nice to
have a sort of high-powered technology
and you know very good ways of sharing
things but if people have been proved
you know 30 years of brutal dictatorship
they don't trust one of those so you
have to figure out how to build that
trust before you can use this technology
so
thank you folks I'll come to you folks
with some have you asked some questions
in a minute but let me just start with
Becca can you just talk about like what
are some lessons from all the different
things that you've done what are some
tips for young people who are thinking
about Occupy Wall Street now that they
can think about about getting there the
people around them engaged with with
Occupy Wall Street you have some tips
that you could check you engage
specifically with Occupy Wall yeah this
is an example sure well maybe I can talk
a little bit about some of the various
meet I mean in many ways absolutely this
is very decentralized and there's a lot
of ways that people are plugging in and
you know we don't even know about it or
we hear about it and we think that's
amazing a you know there's been several
hackathons and other cities to develop
new tools for people to use in activism
contexts and specifically around Occupy
Wall Street absolutely participating in
in Twitter streams and leveraging the
hashtag though at this point it's so
like that thing flies on my tweet taxi
it's really hard to to take part but one
example actually is this has been a big
conversation for the last several weeks
at act by wall street and in some ways
it kind of addresses or speaks to some
of what you're talking about about
democratic frameworks online the General
Assembly that are folks familiar with
how Occupy Wall Street in the Occupy
movements are organized there's every
night a General Assembly and there's the
underpinnings of it our notions of
direct democracy so any voice can block
and there's no amplification so people
use the what's called the people's Mike
there's our technology and we sometimes
technology is really lo-fi radical so in
this case actually think it's that it's
powerful political theater that
functions as like the glue to hold
a lot of the other etic rhetoric and
practice together and and however you
know since Occupy Wall Street scaled so
quickly what were models that were
functional for decision-making on a
smaller scale have become rather
dysfunctional now on a larger scale and
it makes me think about you know the
quicks overall critiques that are coming
out of Occupy Wall Street of our
existing democracy but gosh how do you I
mean I don't want to hold a general
assembly with like 30,000 people and no
microphone no microphone and some people
may not know what people's mike is doing
this explain so you stand up and you say
Mike check and everyone ales back Mike
check and that's a way of like getting
the mic so to speak so you do that a few
times and once you have people's
attention then you'll make your
statement like four words at a time so
you'll say a few words and then people
will repeat it so everyone can hear it
when the crowd grows large enough
there's actually several layers of
representation of repetition so if I
were to say I think that we have to wait
for four I think that wees to travel
through the crowd before I get to pick
up with the rest of the sentence anyhow
it it what I would suggest in many ways
this has resulted in is like there's
this story and the kind of fantasy of
the democracy and how its functioning
and then there's the reality that is not
really the best medium to get any stuff
done quickly ordeal rapid response or
substantive discussion etc and mostly
that happened outside of that space so
Sony how there have been a lot of people
working on structured committees and
trying to introduce and implement new
models modifications of the General
Assembly is the decision-making body
something called a spokes Council model
is one that has been
used in many other movements and it has
proven to be incredibly difficult it has
gone to the general assembly a number of
times but again it's not the best space
to educate and build consensus or buy in
and I think that's the kind of challenge
between like the just you know what I
would call the the tyranny of democracy
sometimes right it's it's it's a
challenge to negotiate so just an
example of the use of social media in
that context several journalists and
people who were tweeting the General
Assembly where the structure
conversation and attempts to implement
the spokes council model were happening
I was home following along and having
had experience with the spokes council
model and other mobilizations just I
just engaged on Twitter for several
hours to affect and influence that
discourse and in a lot of journalists
specifically you know were the ones that
were you know raising questions is the
GA voting itself out of power this is a
terrible thing and SAT around I'm like
well you have no idea on the ground
actually how many of the organizers are
desperate for this and it's coming from
so many different spaces um yeah okay
thank you Mark can you just talk a
little bit about what kind of technology
some of the folks in the audience might
be thinking of learning or picking up
like I noticed there's not a lot of
tweeting going on out of say this even
this session right now so do you want to
give some tips to people on like what
kind of tools that you've seen or
effective and if there are people in the
room we're not using Twitter for example
because they haven't found a reason to
do what they prefer Facebook you want to
talk a little bit about some of those
things and why they should be thinking
about them as well sure absolutely I
would actually echo what you were saying
earlier with you know utilize what
technologies really make sense for your
context everything is going to be so
locally specific in many of the places
what that we work we confront these
issues all the time and in Haiti we were
doing a training with some of our local
staff and notice that they were all
texting each other
quite often and we we asked you know
it's an extremely expensive to to be
texting here just because of the costs
of mobiles and they said that it was
extremely expensive for them and so we
look to Twitter there as actually a mass
free texting system where you by
accessing Twitter from the mobile
gateway you can send a text message to
40404 in Haiti which costs one text
message but then all of the people that
follow you will then get a text message
for free and so rather than having to
text message all these people separately
it can be a rapid response system at
very cost-effective levels so
experimenting with things like that to
see whether it makes sense unfortunately
the delay on on that side made that
model not function but in each context
that's going to be different twitter is
a fantastic tool depending on who your
audience is I know that on Twitter
wherever I go I'm going to be meeting
with in any country that I go to if I
engage on Twitter I can meet some of the
most exciting people who are really at
the cutting edge of understanding their
own culture community and I can connect
to them and meet them for a coffee
without having to have a personal
connection in that country so because I
travel so much that becomes a very
effective tool for me I know that
politicians and journalists are on there
so I can specifically target them to to
engage in conversation but it's really
the plug-in architecture as well knowing
that I can access a geo-located
community saying I'm landing in this
country you know I want tweets only from
this little area and it's some of these
plugins but I've seen a rise in map
based tools there's an exciting project
that we've used and worked with that was
built by Kenyans in Nairobi called
shahidi
and it's a way for people anywhere in
the world to send a text message and
have that message appear onto a map so
this has been used in Haiti we help to
implement that for the response to the
earthquake so how do you get those text
messages and place it onto a map for
people who don't have access to
computers where the UN and others can
come in and actually save lives based on
that information but it's utilizing
wiki's it's it's knowing how some of
these tools operate to then leverage
them for whatever your political or
social goals really are Oh came before
we come out to the audience Ted your
story is fascinating about how you kind
of had worked both in the pre-internet
and post internet worlds are there
specific things that we can learn from
the pre-internet that we can implement
or kind of use today part of this use
the mic please the microphone part of
the point I said of playing with is you
know to some extent you the necessity of
serving you know getting out and you
know so participating instead of dealing
with people on the terms which they find
most appropriate and you notice em and
it's really a question I think is
everybody emphasizes on what people feel
comfortable with and also think that
there's a real difference at some level
between participation on the Internet
where it's easy and you know you can
connect with lots of people if you know
what you're doing but it should keep and
on the other hand what Mark was talking
about being up willing to sort of put
your body on you know in the square you
know to put your body on lined in the
square so you really have to sort of
think about well you know what's easy in
communicative space is not necessarily
powerful in a political space and one of
the things were sort of saved our
projects in Iraq was that we you know we
had sort of been there for 10 years and
we would go back every year or two and
that fact made an enormous amount of
difference so it was the willingness to
sort of figure out how you know
physically being there could you know be
augmented in some way by some small dose
of technology that made projects work
okay thank you let's go to some audience
questions we have a few minutes and then
we wrap up
please geology of digital literacy
governance and organizing I'm thinking
and I'm probably with the gentle over
here pre and post internet at certain
point in your age you will straddle that
line now I'm trying to connect those
three constructs that that you presented
with all of the you know stores of
knowledge where they are like not
digital yet i'm thinking like archives
and depositories where knowledge is
stored for instance say Library of
Congress all of that information is just
sitting somewhere in a vault what
strategy would you propose because I was
trying to figure this governance and and
and and organizing and literacy because
you're going to have a lot of people who
are in these position who are in the
over-50 gang like myself bored in this
position and trying to get access okay
good questions yes um I saw a beautiful
project by the Brooklyn art museum where
they put their archives online and asked
the community to start tagging it so any
photograph just associate one word with
it you know this photograph of black and
white tree and start to really create a
way to engage with their citizenry but
and give new life to their archives in a
way that before would have been very
difficult to do even that process of
categorization etc and provides new
opportunities to to us it's it's very
much about getting access to to data
stores as well in the 21st century being
able to really stand up and say anything
that the government does
we pay for with our taxes so we own the
information that's that they have and
being able to build upon that
information a smarter society not just
saying that before the government may or
may not have been the best in the best
position to make these decisions but now
we can collaborate more so for instance
as becca pointed out the the big apps
per contest where the new york
government has started to give data and
one of the most popular datasets was all
the trees in New York their location
what they are and somebody created an
iphone app that's the most popular
iPhone app that the city has that's come
out of city data just so because people
want to know what the trees are and now
the government could have never known
that this would have been the most
successful app but by providing the data
you create new business and new
opportunities okay thank you next
question please the only reason I work
in Washington Heights not in Haiti or
other countries and the only reason I
ever heard of you sure he'd e orem
Bhutto the one in South Africa or any of
these things is because my husband works
for an NGO that does a lot of
international work and I know so that i
know that there are these countries
where they're not looking to the United
States they don't want to be the next
Silicon Valley they want to be the next
Mumbai and I'm thinking you know there's
all of these global projects and you've
talked about all of these things that
have to do with really changing society
in a big way as well as local issues as
in Haiti but I'm thinking there's so
many ways in which these technologies
need to be taught to our young people
they also need to be utilized for things
like economic revitalization in
neighborhoods for local entrepreneurship
and I'm thinking where are those rfps
where's the money for that who's going
to help develop that because that's
what's really needed yeah to you there's
so much money for it I mean this is this
is the
it it's coming from a million different
places it's not I mean I left it for the
first time in my life left a salaried
position to get into consulting and was
terrified like this was three years ago
in this economic you know precarity
right now is that a good move and it's
no problem finding work and somehow you
know organizations and companies etc the
funding is there because I think people
recognize that this is so if you're if
you're working Washington Heights can
you tap some of these sources for
bringing some of those projects into
places like that well I I mean I think
it's a bit of a research thing to figure
out where are the spaces where there's
organizations whose missions are digital
littered literacy I don't know off the
top of my head but I know that that's a
component of many you know also
companies that invest in that stuff so I
so I think it's a research project but I
would be surprised honestly if that
weren't on the agenda I mean I don't
think it's going to be impossible to
find something like that but I think
also being very proactive in helping the
decision-making process I recently wrote
an article about iPads being the worst
thing that you can give a kid because
it's magic you're giving them something
that's magic they don't understand that
the technology how it works they can't
open it up they can't build anything on
it and so and their productivity you
know what I use an iPad my productivity
is about seventy eighty percent of what
it is on a computer your left slowly
high and it's probably hot is because
I'm a programmer but it's stumping
growth and so being able to participate
proactively to talk to the teachers who
are already overworked and not able to
make their own decisions on this or to
even teach it effectively to help guide
them so finding resources in the
community the right technologist you can
who can help beyond the school board and
participate in the democratic process as
we've had okay Ted will do a time for
one more question after
I think you have a case where sort of
you know that's the class of the
technology has dropped almost 20 and the
problem is defined you know either the
right consultants or to find that you
know the right neighborhood you know the
right set of 14 year olds at some level
and you know if you have a sort of
clearly defined project and you sort of
can get somebody to translate that into
something which is technologically real
it's not going to be that costly to
implement it it's just a matter of
figuring out I mean I think it really is
doing the research that's really being
able to connect your idea with a few
technologists who can do it and then you
know some small source of funding and
you can you almost do it for free at
some level and the thing is this is that
like my generation is the Microsoft Word
generation like we grew up speaking
Microsoft Word this generation is the
social media generation I mean it's
amazing to me even just feel like being
down at Occupy Wall Street folks who are
I college age where teenagers there's no
one like they're so sophisticated
technically and understanding how to use
these tools and how to hack these tools
so we just in some ways we have to get
out of the way or catch up I mean the
digital literacy gap to me is a
generational gap I I disagree excite the
way that i define digital literacy it's
like media literacy it's you can't just
give kids a bunch of newspapers and
expect them to navigate that
particularly well right they might be
reading them but only reading comics etc
I think it's really about giving them
the sense of knowing what is security
knowing what is privacy engaging them
proactively in that conversation because
often the teachers don't have the skills
to do so but they're stepping away and
just seeing where it goes i think is is
where we are currently the way that
we're currently doing it and i think
it's really dangerous okay last question
then i'll ask each of you to give me a
final thought all of you kind of touched
upon the point that there's like a
breakdown between virtual participation
actually participating in political
movements do you foresee a way that that
can be overcome or do you just think
that that's going to remain are we
ality with the social media that we have
okay so maybe if you're going to
incorporate an answer to this into your
final thoughts will be so back up we'll
have you go first sure I think it's a
false dichotomy to say you know there's
like on the ground organizing and then
there's armchair activism and I think
actually you know to speak to your first
question originally how can people
plugin I mean the the amplification and
the spreading you know as a role is
incredibly powerful how quickly how
quickly you know a tutor Iraq veteran
who was hit by a projectile in Oakland's
by the Oakland Police and is now
unconscious in critical condition you
know that happens two nights ago and
that you know by morning was all over
the media and social media helped to
amplify it and became an international
news story and just speaking from the PR
operation or phones ringing off the hook
so it it it accelerates absolutely and
that's a really valuable role to play to
be a digital influencer and you know at
the same time just like check the check
the perspective that it's the social
media revolution because what's less
visible is all the good old-fashioned
organizing that happens and that you
know if that weren't happening that none
of this would happen so I think it's
really it's both bottom-up like the sort
of decentralized distribution channels
plus also tap in the shoulders like if
we just have a narrative that leads to
fret decentralization and fragmentation
as the solution then it's actually hard
to be powerful right okay let's thank
Mecca your hand and she's Becca mo p on
Twitter bek mo p on Twitter let's go to
mark to me the Tea Party and the Occupy
Wall Street protests or something
indicative of what we're starting to
face in the 21st century which
this redefinition of what democracy can
be it's moving beyond left-right
politics institutions are less trusted
now than they've ever been people are
starting to trust one another but the
without an ability to have tangible
information coming from your trusted
sources where your friend might shout
fire even though there's no fire because
of good intentions but not knowing how
to do the right background check rumor
can spread but we're at a point where we
can build on the the data that the
government is giving us and start to
make decisions for ourselves start to
understand where the money is going and
participate in that conversation bring
the recovery.gov data which is all open
we did this with New York Department of
Education where we ask kids okay there's
thirty thousand dollars being invested
in this part of your community and you
know all the money that's going into all
the different parts of your community
what would you do based on this
information and and they came up with
very creative answers based on reality
can we get kids to start manipulating
their own school budget absolutely but
we need to drive that conversation and
know that we can and it's that
personalized democracy based on this
large-scale information sharing that we
now have access to that if we start
building these tools and building the
hackers who can help us build those
tools then then we're really going to
get to a better place with our
democracies thank you Mark and he's em
bielinski MBE li and sk why let's go to
Ted I guess I'd like to sort of focus on
the the question sort of time scale in
the sense that I think you have to sort
of have a short term in a long term
perspective on this because i'm at i
think it's Becca's elephant you know put
it we can't say a hell of a lot louder
than we could in the past but it doesn't
really necessarily means that things are
going to change any faster than they did
in the past in one of the interesting
lessons the 19th century is that it
took 30 or 40 years of activism to get
the vote or to end to end slavery in
some meaningful way and a lot of the
projects that I also work on a genocide
prevention and thinking about changing
the rules a response we protect our also
30 year projects I think you have to
sort of keep in mind the fact that you
can use technology effectively in a
short term but you really have to think
about what is the effect of it long term
and the short term question is tactical
and I'm actually a much more optimistic
on the long term is I really think it
does sort of change the balance of power
and I think you have to sort of think
about what does that mean and how do you
think about that all right let's thank
Ted and he's Ted pearl te d prl on
twitter well thank you all very much and
will hand you over to the final end of
this session thank you everybody thank
you thank you all so I know that a three
at least has a has to leave for another
commitment but again thank you three
mark Becca and Ted and thank you all for
coming for the first annual kenneth cole
community engagement forum we appreciate
it I know some of you were here
throughout the day so thank you all have
a great weekend and thanks for coming